[Música]
quando eu tinha 13 anos de idade
um dia qualquer na saída da escola
eu lembro que eu fiz uma brincadeira uma
brincadeira boba com um rapaz mais velho
e mais alto do que eu
não foi uma boa idéia o rapaz me olhou
chegou perto de mim apontou falou vou te
pegar lá daqui pra frente vai se ver
comigo algumas coisas a mais naquele
momento uma mistura de medo irritação
agonia
voltei pra casa eu lembro que nesse dia
encontrei minha avó minha avó me olhou
com o filho está preocupado meio quieto
está tudo bem e volta tudo bem não
queria preocupar meus pais meus avós
eu mantive aquele estado por algumas
semanas até que eu lembro que encontrei
um texto
o texto falava sobre meditação
transcedental fala de benefícios ao
corpo benefícios a mente e as emoções
achei interessante falei com a minha
família e eles me levaram com 13 anos eu
fiz aquele curso
achei muito aliviar a dor grande parte
de algumas emoções
naquele momento percebi que tinha uma
paixão por meditação queria aprender
estudar e com 13 anos de idade eu passei
a estudar e muitos anos depois já na
faculdade de medicina eu aprendi uma
outra técnica de meditação que eu sigo
até hoje
no final da faculdade eu gostava de
bioquímica reações metabólicas e
dependendo da tecnologia e nem do crime
hoje eu gostava muito do motor de
obesidade ambulatório de obesidade as
pacientes traziam muitas informações
no começo a gente não sabe muita coisa
então elas falavam sobre várias dietas
elas haviam feito nos
últimos tempos com detalhes sobre as
calorias
eu lembro uma vez uma delas falando
sobre a água com a berinjela com limão e
algumas coisas que ela colocava que dava
certo emagrecia anmp eu pensei que eu
sei quantas beringel será que vão isso
era o que parecia ser bom
e elas traziam isso pra gente mas ao
mesmo tempo eu senti uma equitação um
angústia de ter que fazer uma nova dieta
entrava numa dieta sair a nova dieta
entrava e saía culpa porque perdi um
peso e agora ganhavam aquele peso
ganhavam mais ainda uma sensação pessoal
de fracasso porque eu tô se questionavam
iam bem várias áreas da vida na vida
profissional nos relacionamentos
mas nessa questão de perder peso manter
enfim havia uma luta crônica interna com
a comida e eu lembro de um paciente da
vera foi um dos últimos dias que estava
atendendo no ambulatório e agora chegou
pra mim e haverá uma paciente crônica e
ela disse doutor eu quero tentar colocar
por senhor em algumas palavras que
passou um filme que semana passada e
agora chegou chorando e durante a
consulta foi o doutor é semana passada
eu sinto em uma agonia
senti um aperto e aí eu fui até a
cozinha tinha um panetone como um pedaço
de panetone come dois pedaços de
panetone como panetone inteiro
eu fui até o freezer que aquele pote de
sorvete
[Música]
eu dei uma colherada de duas colheradas
estou como o pote de sorvete inteiro
logo depois um arrependimento de logo
depois uma sensação ruim eu passava a
chorar e eu não aguento mais isso
acontecer serão sucessivamente semana
após semana
meses a mesma
naquele momento eu senti aqui o
conhecimento técnico-científico da
medicina ele era bom mas não conseguiu
entrar em contato com aquela luta
interna crônica e quando a gente olha o
cérebro dessas pacientes de fato essa
imagem ilustrativa tanto na forma quanto
no funcionamento em áreas relacionadas à
impulsividade áreas relacionadas emoções
ele é diferente daquelas que não tinham
o que a verba estava escrevendo que era
o transtorno de compulsão alimentar era
muito maior do que imaginava
naquele momento e eu senti uma sensação
de que eu queria ajudar mas não sabia
como atingir isso o tempo passou e aí eu
ouvi um termo que estava no congresso me
falaram de um termo light sweet
como é que é esse tema my trip to me
pronunciar aquilo comer com atenção
plena
achei tão interessante porque juntavam
aspectos de meditação que eu tava
aspectos relacionados à endocrinologia
alimentação e naquele momento parecia
ser bem interessante conhecer aquilo eu
comecei a pesquisar na internet
encontrei o trabalho da professora
christelle a professora critério uma
psicóloga americana praticantes de
meditação e nos últimos 20 anos ela
vinha se dedicado a estudar o mais
influente em comer com atenção plena
elaborado um protocolo é um protocolo de
12 sessões e o que me chama muito
atenção à redução de quase 95% desses
episódios de compulsão alimentar e
algumas pessoas haviam perdido muito
peso outras poucas mas a idéia por trás
disso é que elas perdiam gradativamente
ao longo do tempo
e falava de qualidade de vida enfim foi
uma sensação que eu queria conhecer
eu tive a oportunidade de estar no
passado com ela uma professora que sai
quando ela veio para o brasil e foi um
curso de imersão que a gente ficou dias
e dias ea professora critério uma pessoa
de uma pura que sentia que ela queria
realmente ajudar a beneficiar essas
pacientes e eu fui nesse curso foi nessa
dimensão e no começo era muita meditação
e comida e meditava economia estável
como estava adorando no começo essa
meditação e comida comendo aí o pão de
queijo eu adoro particularmente pão de
queijo com muito pão de queijo e nesse
dia de meditação em particular à medida
que eles estavam me conduzindo com o pão
de queijo
eu lembro muito claro de que eu dei uma
mordida de duas mordidas na e3 mordidas
e ninguém estava impondo nada você
ninguém tava é falando quanto que é o
melhor ou não pra você e eu deixei eu
não comi aquele pão de queijo e foi um
choque estava bem eu estava me sentindo
bem e ninguém havia imposto nada e o que
a professora christa é tava explicando
num imaginem vocês um alimento que eles
gostam bastante então na primeira
mordida daquele elemento tem uma
sensação agradável que vai lá em cima
imagina que a sensação gostosa é um pico
que vai lá em cima e desce a segunda
mordida ainda mantém essa sensação
agradável essa sensação gostosa no
paladar vai lá em cima a partir da
terceira mordida isso cai para 50%
à medida que o tempo vai passando isso
vai diminuindo de menino de milito
naqueles pacientes com compulsão
alimentar havia uma tendência dia o que
ela chamou de ir à caça ao sabor querer
aquela sensação agradável da primeira
medida mas isso não vai mais acontecer
porque porque os receptores do paladar
começar uma faturar
então pelo menos não naquele momento e
essa era uma das idéias é uma das dicas
que a gente pode usar diz que quando tô
comendo com essa tensão e aquele doce
está ficando muito doce
a gordura muito gordurosa é um dos
primeiros sinais que o seu corpo tá te
dizendo que você está bem aqui no
paladar muito antes
sabe aquele chegam o estômago
então aqui ficava uma dica
isso pra mim começou a ficar muito claro
e quando eu estava nesse dia é eu
comecei a perceber a profundidade do que
isso significava a medida que com
algumas técnicas de meditação aumente se
acalmava
a gente saía do automatismo alimentar ea
partir dali começava a entrar na
experiência sentindo o sabor do alimento
com curiosidade com muita abertura e os
pensamentos quando passavam pensamentos
bons pensamentos com índice de emoções
boas emoções com isso era um só
pensamento sun
a gente não se a garrafa mas a eles eu
podia só observava o pensamento a
dimensão e deixava aí nisso era uma
atitude que foi um site para mim porque
era muito mais gentil era muito mais
humano do que eu impor para alguém
enquanto que ele vai comer o próprio
corpo ele ia se autorregulando e foi
muito interessante é pra mim esse
momento é de estar com a professora de
história e um dos exercícios que eu mais
gostei foi da prática nova passo eu
gostaria de trazer pra vocês
agora vamos em um saquinho com 31 da paz
talvez tenhamos se perguntando que esse
brinde inusitada eu ganhei três uvas
passas no ted é prática de agora
então por favor peguem esses saquinho
abram esse saquinho todos com ele
então por enquanto que eu gostaria com
vocês é apenas peguem com uma uva passa
ninguém estava passa e olhem paralelo
apenas olhem para esta uva passa
observe as suas cores
o gol cidade textura olhe para salvar
passa como se fosse a primeira vez que
você estivesse vendo esse alimento como
se fosse um alinhamento exótico imagine
que você chega num lugar que você
encontra um alimento que este alimento
olhem para ele logo a seguir podem
fechar os olhos
levem até o nariz e se então cheiro tava
passa-se tão cheio desse pequeno pedaço
de alimento alguma algum pensamento
acontecendo neste momento apenas observa
então passe ao redor dos lábios passa ao
redor dos lábios
a uva passa de um lado para o outro
então podem levar à boca mas não
mastigam ainda apenas coloquem na boca e
passem de um lado para o outro
de um lado para o outro resistindo aqui
em curso de modelo alfa paz como é isso
pra você e agora pode dar a primeira
mordida nova praça
e vejam sabor sentindo um sabor surgindo
a seguinte a seguir podem morder
continuar morando morder a uva passa e à
medida que tiverem prontos podem incluir
imagina no trajeto até o estômago
e agora peguem a segunda uva passa
da mesma forma se houver o a passo
da mesma forma
olhem para salvar passa e procure
observar a cor textura o gol cidade é
igual é diferente daquela primeira então
levem ao nariz podem fechar os olhos
passem ao redor dos lábios coloquem na
boca passando de um lado para o outro
resistindo ao impulso de morteiro alguma
emoção particular surgindo neste momento
apenas observa
então podem moderar a uva passa e à
medida que se sentirem prontos podem
engolir
ea seguir para quem tiver pegue a
terceira curva passa a ideia importante
de ficar novamente e olhe para esta
terceira uva passa
neste momento eu gostaria que vocês
fizessem uma escolha para aqueles que
tiverem você pode comer este alimento ou
não
não há certo ou errado apenas olhe para
ele perceba se você tem ou não um
impulso à vontade de comer a relva passa
neste momento se você quiser reproduza
quiser comer reproduz o que eu os
orientei da primeira segunda vez se não
deixe de lado mas apenas esteja ciente
de porque você fez essa escolha
então para aqueles que fizeram
não importa a 0 não fizeram essa
experiência que vocês podem levar com
vocês perceberam emoções sensações
surgindo
a ideia é apenas observar sem julgamento
sem crítica de uma forma mais gentil
consigo mesmo
talvez tenha sido a primeira experiência
11 a comer com atenção plena e para
aqueles que sentiram algumas sensações
surgindo todos nós temos um certo grau
enorme maior de compulsão alimentar
isso pode ajudar bastante apenas
pratiquem sem muitas expectativas
façam façam e vejam o que surge esta uma
pergunta será que todo esse protocolo as
duas sessões que a professora ester
elevador ou será que é capaz de naqueles
pacientes com obesidade compulsão
alimentar alterar a forma de
funcionamento do cérebro
isso a gente não sabe ainda é quem está
começando a pesquisar na santa casa de
são paulo
daqui uns anos talvez a gente tenha um
pouco mais de resposta sobre isso e para
aqueles que se perguntam o que aconteceu
com três anos de idade
aquele rapaz praticamente mudou o curso
da minha vida tomou uma surra dele na
verdade fisicamente não há muitos anos
se passaram ele chama rodrigo e muitos
anos depois reencontrei rodrigo e eu
olhei pra ele olhou pra mim ele nem se
lembrava direito de quem era aquele
momento foi impactante para mim na
verdade ele quase não causou impacto
depois de dessa jornada eu como missão
pessoal é de encontrar e perceber
o quanto que há sofrimento dessa
compulsão alimentar no transtorno de
compulsão alimentar ver que tem uma
alternativa mais humana só tem
alternativa mais gentil
eu gostaria todo o coração é divulgar
para vocês que há essa possibilidade
chamada my sweet obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]